NASEER MOHAMMAD: Welcome.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Naseer Mohammad.
And--
CHRIS PAGE: I'm Chris Page,
customer solutions architect
with Apigee, part
of Google Cloud.
NASEER MOHAMMAD:
And today, we will
be talking about securing
your APIs with Apigee.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So with that, let's get started.
These are our names.
These are our pictures.
And here's the agenda.
So today, we will go over
a brief overview of Apigee
and then do a deep dive
of Apigee Edge security.
We'll follow that up
with a demo, a cool demo
that Chris is going to show.
And then we will open it up
for questions and answers.
So what is Apigee?
Apigee a comprehensive
API platform.
It provides three core modules--
API management module that
is responsible for providing
development and
management of API proxies.
Developer services
is a module that
is responsible for providing
a fully managed and highly
engaging developer portal.
And then the analytics module--
the analytics module
will give you visibility
in the usage of
your APIs, thereby
providing you the visibility
for the effectiveness,
for you to analyze the
effectiveness of your API
program.
Apigee's also the
industry leader
for three consecutive years,
being on the top right
of the Magic Quadrant.
And this is the
philosophy of Apigee--
thinking outside in.
This philosophy at
Apigee challenges
traditional approaches
of API management.
Traditionally, the thing
about API management
in terms of exposure,
you have services
which you want to expose.
So you come up with APIs, and
you publish an API catalog.
And you think the job is done.
Well, not really.
If you think about it from
an end user perspective
and work backwards from there,
that leads to better results.
And also too, realizing
the importance
of each actor on this
chain and providing them
with enhanced experiences while
they interact with your API
platform becomes the key for
a successful API program.
And using this platform and
using this design pattern,
we have shown success
to many of our clients.
Now having said that, let's
change the role, right?
Let's change the
lens of this pattern.
Let's look at this pattern
in terms of security.
You know, you'll see we
cover a lot of ground
here, which opens up a room
for a lot of security controls
to be in place.
So each actor on this
chain presents a unique set
of security
requirements, and we will
go through these requirements.
And I want you guys, while I'm
walking through this flow here,
I want you to relate to your use
cases, your API use cases which
you are working on,
and see how you're
addressing the
security concerns which
I'm going to walk through here.
So let's start this
exercise from left to right.
On the left, while we publish
our APIs on the internet,
how do we protect these
APIs from hackers?
When I say hackers, in
the back of your mind
you should be thinking
about SQL injection
threatening content
protection, denial of service,
et cetera, right?
So how can we protect
our APIs from hackers
who are trying to
bring your system down?
And how can we protect from data
scrapers, the data scrapers who
are trying to steal our data
for their competitive advantage?
Leading to the next
security concern,
which is how do
you authenticate,
and how do you know if
the incoming users are
legitimate users, and
if he or she really
have the needed permissions
to access these APIs?
Likewise, applications--
and enterprise
can have many applications.
How can you identify
these applications?
How can you make
sure the APIs that
are invoked from
these applications
are legit APIs or all
APIs that are allowed
for this application to invoke?
And more importantly,
as we are talking,
or we are looking from a
security and [INAUDIBLE]
perspective, how do you ensure
that a decommissioned app can
no longer access these APIs?
Moving further towards the
right comes in developer.
The app developers
create great apps.
Now how can we help them
on-board on the API platform?
How can we register these app
developers on the API platform,
providing them the
appropriate set of controls,
or appropriate set of
APIs which they can
access, without much friction?
And that becomes a key.
Moving for the
right in the chain
comes the APIs
and the API teams.
Now this poses a
very interesting
and a critical
security concern, which
is how do you ensure that
the API developers know
what they are developing
with respect to security?
Are they opening up
any vulnerabilities
while they're
developing these APIs?
Are they adhering to
enterprise standards
while they're
developing these APIs?
That becomes a critical concern.
And then finally
on the back end,
how do you authenticate
to back end?
How do you pass
in to the back end
the information of the
original requester that
invoked this API?
And how do we address data
security on wire, in transit,
and at rest?
So these are the concerns that
comes up, and the list is long.
Now let's see how Apigee
provides or addresses
some of the security concerns.
Let's start from
left to right again.
Apigee provides a behavior-based
threat protection model
to protect our APIs from
hackers and data scrapers.
Apigee also protects our
APIs from threatening content
protection by providing
threatening content protection
policies--
attacks like SQL
injection, attacks
like cross-site scripting
attacks, XML bombs,
or XML reference attacks.
Apigee can have a
signature-based threat
protection policy deployed to
take care of these attacks.
Apart from this, as you
publish your APIs on internet,
your APIs are prone
to spikes in traffic.
Apigee effectively protects
against spikes of traffic,
thereby preventing our back
end systems going down.
Apigee identifies
applications using API keys
and authenticate end
users using OAuth,
the industry standard
authentication protocol.
Apigee provides all five
grant types of OAuth.
Apigee also can act as a fully
compliant authorization server
and an OAuth resource server.
After addressing
the identification
and authentication
problems, the next challenge
would be the
authorization challenge,
which becomes a very
complex challenge
to address or to solve.
Apigee addresses
this in two fashions.
Apigee divides the
authorization space into two--
course-grained
authorizations and
fine-grained authorizations.
For course-grained
authorization,
Apigee introduces this
concept called API products.
API products help
you slice and dice
your APIs that makes
business sense.
Now this API products,
in turn, will also
act as your
authorization enforcers.
Similarly, you can have quota
enforcement on the products,
right?
Now when it comes to
fine-grained authorizations,
Apigee provides your
tools and policies
to implement scope-based
access control
policies and claims-based
access control policies,
leveraging OAuth
scopes and JWT tokens.
Apigee provides logging
capabilities for auditability,
thereby covering identification,
authentication, authorization,
and auditability
aspects of security.
Apigee provides for
developers developer portal
and also management
APIs for them
to have a single sign on and
self-registration features
for them to log-in to
the developer portal
and start using the APIs.
Apigee can also work with
your identity provider
which you have at
your enterprise--
products like PingFederate,
SiteMinder, [INAUDIBLE],,
or what have you.
As long as these products
support OAuth, SAML,
OpenID-based connect
protocols, Apigee
can integrate with your
identity providers,
thereby providing single sign
on authentication for your app
developers.
Apigee can also work
with your partners.
Apigee can authenticate
your partners and also
the users and app developers or
internet using OpenID Connect
and SAML protocols.
When it comes to
security and governance
and ensuring that your API
development team is really
developing APIs and not
opening up vulnerabilities,
Apigee provides a cool feature,
which is known as flow hooks.
Flow hooks externalizes
the security responsibility
from an API proxy developer.
Thereby, a security expert can
go in and develop his policies
and auto-apply the
security policies
to the policies that are
developed your API proxy
developers.
Thereby, API proxy
developers need not
worry about
implementing security.
And it gets auto-enforced
while the API proxies
are being executed at runtime.
Apigee provides
confidentiality for data online
and also data at rest,
providing the TLS capabilities
for one-way and two-way TLS for
both northbound traffic that
is coming into Apigee and
southbound traffic that
is leaving from Apigee
to your data centers.
So these are some
of the features
which Apigee provides
with respect to security
at a high level.
Now today, we will go over
signature-based threat
prediction module.
That's where Chris will
start his demo and showcase
how you can leverage Apigee for
implementing threat protection.
CHRIS PAGE: Thanks, Naseer.
Let's talk a little bit more
details about that problem.
API ecosystems can receive
malicious client attacks
from both internally
as well as externally.
Those malicious clients
will send malformed requests
to your back end systems.
The API proxy layer can
detect, block, and report
those malformed client
payloads and will
inspect the query parameters,
the headers, as well
as the payloads, and block
them or report them before they
hit the back end systems.
As you can see from
this diagram below,
the malicious client is sending
both an HTTP post as well as
a GET in trying to attack
the back end service.
Now Open Web Application
Security Project
is an open community
that focuses
on the best practices of
application and API governance
around security protocols.
Every year, they
publish a top 10 list
of what enterprises
should be looking
at when they're applying these
different types of threat
protections.
We're going to focus today
on the number one, injection
flaws.
It's been number one for
probably the last eight
years running.
Input validation
is when the client
submits semantical or
syntactical different types
of data where the structure
can be nested structure,
like if you have a key value
pair in a JSON payload, what
happens if you nest multiple
arrays or multiple hashes
within that key value?
As well as
understanding the value
or the limit of those different
query parameter fields--
let's say I only request or
only require a limit name
in brewery in my API.
And then the second
injection flaw
that we're going to take a
look at is SQL code injection.
This is commonly noted where a
malicious client will actually
send malformed or
contextual-aware text
that can actually pinpoint and
hit your database layer where,
i.e., for a relational delete
from a particular schema,
like delete from resource.
This can be applied for SQL code
injection, not just relational,
but also non-relational as well.
So with the API itself in the
demo, we have a beer service.
And that beer service provides
a list of JSON details
about beers.
Apigee will be the
enforcement point
so that you can have the
good requests go through.
But the bad requests,
we're actually
going to block them and
return bad requests or 400
back to the client, as
well as log on them.
So the goals of
this demo is create
an API proxy that protects
against OAuth injection flaws
from the client
request payloads,
as well as query parameters.
We're going to keep it
as simple as possible
so that we can walk through and
show you all the details of all
the policy itself.
And third, let's report on the
usage so that we can identify,
and some of our API
teams or business folks
can actually learn about
from an analytic perspective.
Now, let's take a
look at the API.
So I'm logging-in to Apigee.
And I am going to go into
Apigee Edge in the Management
interface.
I'm going to take a look at
the API I built for this demo.
I call it the Beers On-Air Demo.
And I'm going to go
over to the Develop tab.
I'm going to pop this
open a little bit.
From the Develop
tab, you are going
to see a palette of
different configuration,
or what we call policies.
Within each one
of these policies,
you can apply different
threat protections
or different enforcement.
The policies themselves
are broken up
into Traffic Management,
Security, as well as Mediation.
And you have a whole
palette of easily
over 30 different policies
that you can apply
to your particular API proxy.
For this particular proxy,
we're going to look initially
at JSON threat protection.
And this has to do with
those input injections
or validations of the client
sending malformed request
payloads.
So in this particular
example, I'm
going to look for a
particular container depth.
I'm going to make sure there's
no arrays within my structure.
only three keys in my object
entry.
I'm going to make sure the
object length of those names
is only 50 characters.
I'm also going to make
sure the value is not
over 255 characters.
Now, the API itself--
let me just open this up.
And of course, the API
doesn't want to work.
There we go.
My API is returning
a list of JSON data
about that information.
Now, I already went ahead
and created a client.
I have a simple single-page app.
Once I go to my single-page app,
I need to authenticate my user.
So I'm just going to do a
simple demo user for today.
We're going to do--
let's do a JWT token.
Once I have my token, I'm
going to actually make
a successful request
to that back end API.
Now with the platform
itself, we also
have the ability to do
real-time debugging.
So if I go open
to my proxy again,
we have a concept
called Trace, which
allows me to do real-time trace
debugging of that proxy itself.
So let me start that trace
section so that you actually
can see the successful requests
going through initially.
I'll hit that refresh again.
And actually, I'll
send a filter.
[? Mean ?] equals L. You'll
see that it's filtered.
And when I actually
go into my trace,
I actually can walk
through each one
of those individual policies
that I've defined for my threat
protection and make sure that
everything is going through,
and the client is
receiving those requests.
So that's an example of
the successful request.
Well, let's take a look
and let's try and implement
that JSON threat protection.
So I'll reset this.
Let's create a new beer.
Let's just call
it a sample beer.
We'll have the Google
brewery, and we'll
make it On-Air for the style.
Once I make that success,
you'll see my new beers there.
I'll go back to my trace.
You'll see that the
201 was created,
so it was successful request
for actually a post coming
right there.
Now actually, I'm
going to go back.
I'm going to send a
malformed-- or I'm
going to send a character string
over 255 characters, which
I defined in that JSON
threat protection.
A lot of the times,
clients will have that
on client-facing validation.
But if that's not
there, this is going
to simulate what happens when
a malicious client's going
to send that.
So let's do a random characters.
Let's do 256.
Pipe that too.
So I'm going to
change the name now
to that random array
of 256 characters.
And I'll just put a bunch
of brewery and style
for my parameters.
Immediately, once I
clicked Submit or Save,
I receive that 400
error on my client.
You'll see there's
details within the body
of the response coming back that
I'm displaying for this demo.
Basically, the JSON threat
protection was caught,
and there is exceeded
string length at line 1.
Once I go back to my
real-time trace debugger,
you'll see that
400 that came in.
And I can walk through exactly
which policies were triggered
within my Policy window.
You'll see that this
little icon right here,
"Execution error for JSON threat
protection," basically that
is where my API proxy was
able to inspect the payload
and realize that that string
character was over that limit.
So that was the first example.
Let's take a look at
the second example.
So second example, we're going
to do parameter validation.
And parameter
validation, I'm going
to use the ability within
our API manager platform
to call out JavaScript
and do some business
logic to validate those
particular parameters that
are coming in.
You'll see that this policy
is actually going to call this
parameter_validation.js.
I have a set of
valid parameters,
as well as some of
the pagination that
is in my application.
And I'm going to check the
length of those parameters,
making sure the
length is not greater
than what is white listed
here, as well as I'm going
to iterate over the parameters.
And if any of the parameters
that are sent from the client
are going I'm fail out, and
fail gracefully, and send back
that error to the client.
So let's try this one out.
My trace is still running.
I'm going to go
to my application.
Let's go to-- you'll
see before that I
can filter with
a successful name
parameter as a white
listed URL parameter.
What happens if I do
something like this?
Users-- oh, just like
that, another 400 error.
This time, it's just like
before-- the JSON validation
error.
This time, I'm getting
a different validation.
I'm getting
parameter validation.
And they'll see that this
user is not a valid parameter.
Likewise, when I go back
to the trace debugger,
I can actually
trace through here.
And when the JavaScript
was executed,
and actually it's going
to trigger a variable.
And that variable is going to
set a custom error message.
This custom error message
is called raise parameter
validation fault. So
within your policies,
you can use out-of-the-box ones,
or you can define additional
custom ones, like I did
here and with JavaScript.
That's example number two.
Let's take a look at
the third example.
Let me go back to my flow.
Last example is called
SQL code protection.
And SQL code is that
common regex or string
that malicious
clients try to inject
to manipulate the data
structures of your database
layer.
And a lot of
[? allocations ?] leverage
ORM or different
types of libraries
to escape out some
of those regexes
or escape out some of
those single quotes.
Sometimes, that's
not always the case.
And sometimes, you
need to enforce that
within the API proxy layer.
So a SQL code protection--
I'm actually going to check for
different regexes, like DELETE,
EXECUTE, or DROP, INSERT, or
various different SQL regex
or SQL code key parameters
that a malicious client would
be sending.
So let's double-check.
Let's see if my trace
is still running.
Yep, I've still got
some time going here.
I'm going to go back.
I'm going to reset
my application.
You'll see that I have a
successful request coming in.
This time, let's simulate a
malicious client that's going
to try to DELETE from Beers.
Let's say if it tries to
delete from my Beer schema.
Oh, just like before,
I got another 400
back from a bad request
from my API proxy layer.
You'll see that the details
in that false string,
the regular expression
threat detected
was the SQL code protection.
And just like before, if I walk
through my real-time debugger
within my trace section, you'll
see that this time, request
was received for client,
validated the client,
went through, JSON threat
protection was passed,
parameter validation was passed.
This time, SQL code protection
was actually triggered here,
and the proxy was hit.
Now that was how we
enforce different policies
from a threat
protection standpoint.
Let's take a look at what's
available for reporting
and the third thing
of how we want
to see how we report on
those different metrics.
So within Apigee,
you have the ability
to send custom reports
or custom logging
within your proxy layer.
So with these individual
threat protections,
I'm actually going to look
for a particular string
or particular validation when
the applications send it.
So this error code,
I'm actually going
to capture this error
code within my policy
and then send that to
Apigee's rich analytics engine
so that we can have
real-time dashboards
on the amount of threats that
are coming into my system.
That is one way to
capture the analytics.
The other way would be to send
to your additional southbound
or northbound systems of
your monitoring systems--
your sys logs, your
SNMP agents, or any
of the event-driven
agents that can
capture these different
information to report from a VI
perspective.
So let's take a
look at my policies
that I have added for that.
Within my fault rules,
I have a policy called,
Extract fault error codes.
And this policy
is actually going
to look at the JSON payload
or the JSON structure
when a fault is triggered.
So I'm actually going
to use JSON path here.
The JSON path schema
is actually going
to look for that error
code and actually capture
that as a separate variable,
called fault error code, here.
Once I capture that
error code, I'm
actually going to use the
statistics collector policy
within Apigee that allows me to
send custom statistic metrics
to our analytics engine.
So the fault collector
policy, you'll
see that I'm actually going to
create a new statistics value,
called fault_errorcode,
which is going
to reference that
variable I just
created from that JSON path.
Then I'm going to store that
into our analytics engine.
So if I go back to
my flow within here,
you'll actually see
that those policies
are being executed on every
fault that's being triggered.
So if I click Next
within my trace debugger,
you'll see that that
SQL code protection
was triggered right here.
And then if I scroll down,
you will see there is--
where is it?
I am going to-- let me
just walk over once more.
Here it is.
So here is the error
content that was triggered
from that SQL code protection.
You'll see that that JSON
structure is right here.
Here is that fault
error code that I'm
capturing from that policy.
So this fault error code
will be unique for each one
of my policies so that I
can report on accordingly.
Once I hit Next, you'll see
the statistics collector is
actually going to
take that policy,
and then there's an additional--
if a particular
error message occurs,
I don't want it to
send a 500 back.
But so let's go back
to our analysts engine.
So within Apigee, you have the
ability to see client traffic.
You have the ability to
see user-based traffic,
proxy-based traffic,
product-based traffic.
You have a rich
analytics engines
that allows you to dive in
into each individual policy
to learn more about how your
API program or your API proxies
are performing.
So if I go into that custom
reporting that I created,
I have already created a report,
called fault error codes.
That fault error
codes, actually,
you'll see right
here, is reporting
on each individual fault that
I enabled within my policies.
You'll see that
this invalid access
token was when I was not
authenticated or authorized
from my client app.
But more specifically, here
is the JSON threat protection.
Here was the
parameter validation,
and here's the regex protection.
So I can dive into
each one of these
and learn a little bit
more about each one
of those anomalies.
So as your API ecosystem, or as
your API platform is evolving,
you'll see more and more
of this information that
will be useful to block
and understand what
those different types of
threats that are coming in.
So I'm going to reset that.
And that actually
concludes the demo.
I'm going to go back to my list.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Sweet.
That was a nice demo.
So we'll open up for
questions and answers?
CHRIS PAGE: Before we do that--
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Yep.
[AUDIO OUT]
CHRIS PAGE:
[INAUDIBLE],, you feel
free to sign up on apigee.com
to get your own free trial.
We also have hands-on
enablement where
you can go through a
virtual gem or on-site gem
to learn more about the
different functionality
and have your teams be
hands-on into that process.
And on top of that, we actually
have product demo webinars,
like this today.
But let's stay tuned
for a live Q&A.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Sure.
CHRIS PAGE: And we can be
back in less than a minute.
Looks like we have some great
questions from the audience.
Thank you, very much.
First question-- does SQL
code protection policy only
apply to relational databases?
I'll take this one, Naseer.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Sure.
Yep.
CHRIS PAGE: So as
I mentioned before,
the policy itself is
actually regular expression.
So it can be applied to
all aspects of the client
requests coming in.
A lot of the traditional
relational databases
have that SQL statement
that is more prominent.
With NoSQL coming into play,
a lot of malicious clients
are actually also
taking advantage
of those different types of
syntactical URL parameters.
So the same type of SQL
code protection policy
that I applied for
DELETE from schema
can also be applied for
particular key spaces
or different
structures of NoSQL.
So that also can apply to
non-relational databases.
Next question-- should
an ORM database framework
library handle all of
SQL injection protection?
That's another great one.
Many different
software languages
have many different
libraries where developers
feel comfortable that
that library abstracts out
with object relational
mapping libraries
so that, when they build
out their applications,
that they think they're
protected from a security
standpoint.
There are a lot of flaws in
some of those frameworks,
and we still recommend that a
SQL code protection or a threat
protection is layered on
top the API proxy layer
to protect against some of those
ORM frameworks that have flaws.
Actually, we just read about
one from a NoSQL library
that actually opened up based
off the ORM database framework.
Great question.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Yeah,
just to add on that.
So think about this as a
layered framework, right?
Apigee sits in the first
layer, acts like [INAUDIBLE]..
And you're protecting
all your security--
providing all your security
controls at Apigee.
And then when the call goes into
your internet or the back end,
it's already protected.
So we need security
at each layer,
just to make sure
that we are having
security controls at each layer,
and there's no hack happening
from any of those layers.
So that's that.
The next question in here is, as
new OWASP rules are published,
can the API threat
protection policies
be updated dynamically?
Wow.
So this is a very
interesting question, right?
So the bigger question
behind the question
really is if, let's say
you develop an API proxy
and have the regular expression
which we got from OWASP
injected into the proxy itself.
It's going to be
kind of hard coded
for that particular
regular expression.
Now, as in when
OWASP is publishing
new regular expirations, how
can we make it more dynamic?
And this a very
interesting question.
One approach you can take
is, rather than hard coding
the regular expression
in the proxy itself,
you might want to refer
to that regular expression
with a key value, right?
So you might want to store
your regular expression
in our key value map
storage, wherein you can
refer to a regular expression.
For example, let's say it was
SQL injection specifically
for insert attack, right?
So the key would be [?
SQLInjection_insertAttack.
?] And then you can refer
the value from the KVM.
And that gets pulled
in dynamically.
Now the other part
to this would be,
how would you hook up
your OWASP updating
your regular
expression to Apigee?
That, you can do
through management API.
So Apigee provides management
API capabilities for you
to update key value maps.
Or anything which
you can do on a UI,
there's a management
API for that, right?
So in this case, you would
leverage the management API
and tie in OWASP's updates
to trigger an update
in your key value map.
Thereby, you need not really
re-deploy your policies
or recreate your proxies, right?
This becomes dynamic
and adds a lot of value.
CHRIS PAGE: Yeah.
So from a programmatic
standpoint,
that can be automated
for your CIC pipeline.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Oh, yeah.
CHRIS PAGE: Great.
Great point.
Nice.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Definitely.
So the other question
we have here is,
how can you monitor
malicious clients and pattern
matching on rule-based filters?
Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
So Apigee provides
behavior-based threat
protection modules for you.
And it's very configurable.
Matter of fact, we are
doing another live webinar
wherein we will showcase
Apigee Sense and all
of its capabilities in detail.
But the short answer in
here is, you would configure
your clients on
Apigee Sense, and you
will define rules based on
which Apigee Sense will mark
a client as a malicious
client, or the client which
is a known client, but it
has its so and so usage
requirements.
And that's the reason why it's
sending so much traffic to you.
CHRIS PAGE: That's a good point,
because a lot of the threat
protections that I apply are
more and more per request.
But if you look at
those trends over time,
how do you take a look at those
risk patterns and those threat
patterns for a larger data set?
Almost like looking at
big data and actually
using machine learning to
determine what those rules are
for understanding what those
malicious clients and patterns
are.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Totally.
So the other question
which we have in here
is, how do we have
the flow hooks which
are used for security controls
configured differently
based on different clients?
So how can we really do?
That's a really good question.
So the question, again,
to go back and relate
to what we're talking
about in here,
is the ability which Apigee
provides you to externalize
enterprise security rules and
policies so that the enterprise
security engineer can develop
the policies, the security
policies for you.
But the real question which
you guys are asking in here
is, how can you have
different rules applied
based on who the client is,
who the partner is, right?
And you know, that's
really a valid use case.
You might want a higher quota
for your premium clients,
and a lower quota for your
gold or silver clients, right?
Also too, some of
your clients might
want to come and authenticate
to you over OAuth.
And some might want to
authenticate to you over SAML.
And a single policy can't
cater to all of these needs,
and thereby, leading to
a multi-profile security.
The way you will
achieve this in Apigee
is by what is known as
profile-based security.
In Apigee, you can define
multiple security profiles.
And these security
profiles can be
configured for your customer.
I'm just giving
this example, right?
Let's say Bank of America is
making a call to your APIs.
And then Wells Fargo is
And Bank of America wants to
authenticate to you over SAML.
And Wells Fargo wants to
authenticate to you over OAuth.
The cool thing that Apigee
does-- it first of all,
starts your security
process with identification.
You identify who the
caller is, and then you
authenticate the caller.
And then you authorize
the caller, right?
CHRIS PAGE: Yep.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: So once
the identification part
is done, at Apigee, you would
know who the end user is.
In this case, it would be
Bank of America, right?
And then you would
direct your flow hook
to a security profile that is
applicable for Bank of America.
Thereby, might be Bank
of America wants SAML,
and you go through
SAML authentication
and then authorizations.
Similarly, if it
is Wells Fargo, you
would let them
through other channel.
And that's actually a
very good pattern, right?
There's a community article,
if I remember it right,
which is titled,
"Multi-Profile Security,
Implementing Multi-Profile
Security at Your Enterprise."
We just lost the screen,
so let's go through
and see the questions.
CHRIS PAGE: I think it's
good for a summary for now
of what we accomplished today.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Right.
Sure.
CHRIS PAGE: So Apigee is
the API management platform
that allows you to enforce
security policies that
protect against OAuth
threat protection.
We have the flexibility to
do that programmatically
and apply some of
the best practices
from a standards-based
community.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: That's good.
And you know, like I
started with an overview
of all the features
of Apigee security.
Today, we focused on the
threat [INAUDIBLE] protection.
But stay tuned for more such
calls, more such sessions
wherein we'll be talking about
other aspects of security,
like authentication, single
sign on, authorizations,
coarse-grain authorizations,
fine-grain authorizations,
in detail.
CHRIS PAGE: Yeah.
OK.
NASEER MOHAMMAD:
Thank you, so much.
And stay tuned.
So let's go to the next slide.
What's the next--
there's a next session
which is happening
follow-up after this.
So that is-- oh yeah.
So the-- like-- no, there
is another session happening
that's getting started with
kubeflows for Kubernetes.
Sounds interesting.
CHRIS PAGE: Oh, yes, from an
orchestration service mesh.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Nice.
CHRIS PAGE: Sounds good.
NASEER MOHAMMAD: Right.
CHRIS PAGE: Appreciate the time.
Thank you, very much.
NASEER MOHAMMAD:
Thank you, so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]